okay
final objection to
refute why didn't Jesus say I am God
worship me in those exact words here's
why get ready I've answered this a
million times for a first century Jew
the term
God
typically was used to refer to the
Father in
Heaven I've done sessions on this same
pathetic argument why didn't Jesus say I
am God in those exact words to a first
century Jew the word god typically
referred to the
Father the predominant usage of
God would be in reference to the father
it's just like the word Adam Adam when
you say
Adam you immediately associate Adam with
the first male the husband of Eve so
like the word God the word Adam
typically
denotes the first male the male the
first human male created the husband of
Eve but we both know that Adam is simply
the Hebrew word for mankind humanity and
that Eve was also called Adam do me a
favor brother ahmedani post Genesis 5
ver2 okay watch
here and I'll give you an example male
and female created he them notice male
and female created he them plural
blessed them called their name Adam and
the day when they were created wait male
and female their name was Adam so Eve
was Adam and the male who married her
was Adam yes but in the New Testament
and among
Christians typically refers to the male
the male
M okay the male the husband of Eve what
if I were to say to you guys Adam got
pregnant and gave birth to Cain and Abel
you look at me baffled bewildered
perplexed what are you talking about man
Adam got pregnant gave birth to Cain and
Abel what dude are you are you accusing
Adam being
transgender gender
confusion what you Adam got
pregnant Adam was pregnant and she gave
birth to Cain and
Abel now how many of you would be
confused I would lose almost anyone and
everyone who doesn't know what the Bible
teaches but I'm right Adam did get
pregnant she did give birth to Canan
CU you just read Genesis
5:2 Eve was also named Adam like her
husband and exactly David Stenberg their
sons are also Adam because the term Adam
is used for humankind So Adam got
pregnant and she gave birth to two who
are Adam she gave birth to two who were
Adam so Adam was and she gave birth to
Adam and Adam's brother who's named
Adam but that would create confusion
wouldn't
it that would create confusion
right yeah Jeremy let me repeat in
Genesis 52 Jeremy is Eve called Adam
let's look at it again Genesis
5:2 male and female created he them and
blessed
them and called their name Adam in the
day when they were created so isn't Eve
Adam yes so if Eve is
Adam wasn't Adam pregnant yes didn't she
Adam give birth to an Adam yes and then
give birth to another Adam yes because
Cain is Adam Abel is Adam Eve is Adam
and the male who married her is
Adam you guys got to get it before I
move
on Adam is a name that refers to all
human beings who possess human nature
human Essence human characteristics if
you're a human you're
Adam if you're a human male you're Adam
if you're female you're Adam your
children are
Adam but would that communicate clearly
or would that create contradiction and
confusion if I come and say Adam was
pregnant and she gave birth to Cain and
Abel people would be perplexed what are
you talking
about it's a name and a title it's a
name and a title similarly for a first
century Jew for a first century
Jew to say I am God would be confusion
because to them God meant the Father in
heaven so if Jesus simply said I am God
and then qualify it they would say so
you're the father in heaven then what
are you doing on
Earth God is our father who's in heaven
since Jesus is not the
father but the The Father's son who's
equal with him in essence how could
Jesus communicate the fact I am not the
father I'm the son of the father who is
equal to the father and Essence and
therefore just as much God as he is the
only way he could do so without
confusing them is the way we find him
speaking in the gospels and how does he
speak in the gospels
reaffirming reiterating hammering the
fact I am the Son of God who does things
that only God can do and does everything
that the father does because I'm one
with him in essence and they got it oh
so you a man claim to be God you're not
the father you're the son of the father
and yet you're the son of father in such
a way where you claim to be God like the
father is blasphemy because all you are
is a
man in other words there was no better
way for Jesus to affirm that he's God In
the Flesh without confusing his audience
into thinking he's the father than the
way he speaks in the gospels I'm not the
father I'm the Son of God but I can do
everything the father does the way the
father does it but hold on the father
does things that only God can do you're
not the father but you're the son who
does everything the father does in the
same way he does it who Do You Think You
Are God In the Flesh yes
exactly let me show you that from
the gospels John 10:27
to30 John 10:27
to30 John 10:27 to30 my sheep hear my
voice and I know them and they follow me
and I give unto them eternal life no
creature can say I give all believers
NeverEnding life and they shall never
perish neither shall any man pluck them
out of my hand no creature can claim to
be all powerful over creation to
guarantee the Eternal preservation of
all believers no creature can say what
Jesus said I give all sheep eternal life
no one can destroy them and snatch them
out of my hand of protection and power
and
preservation no creature can speak this
way okay my Father which gave them me is
greater than all and no man is able to
pluck them out of my father's and see my
father is Mighty over creation no one
can snatch Believers out of his hand
because he's
Almighty no power can rival his
guaranteeing their Eternal preservation
no power can pluck them out of my hand
as well why because I'm one with my
father in our ability to preserve all
believers
immortally this is a claim of being God
Almighty in the flesh but notice he said
he's the son not the father I am one
with my father so I'm not my father and
I'm one with him now notice how they
understood him John 10
31-33 John 10
31-33 and we'll be done then the Jews
took up stones again to Stone him Jesus
answered them many good works have I
showed you from my father for which of
those Works do you Stone me now notice
the Jews answered him saying for good
work we Stone them thee not but for
blasphemy and because that thou being a
man makest thyself God see they got it
Jesus being the perfect Communicator who
speaks perfectly knows his audience
perfectly and knows how to get the point
across to his audience I'm not the
father I am God but I'm not the father
so how does Jesus do that speaking the
way he does I am the Son of God I'm one
with my father in his power and ability
to give Immortal Incorruptible
NeverEnding life and to preserve all
believers from ever being destroyed by
anyone wow only God can give NeverEnding
Immortal Incorruptible life only God is
powerful enough to guarantee that no
power or creature will destroy any
believer in his hand of protection but
you just claim that for yourself but at
the same time time you're a man and at
the same time you're not the father
you're the Father's son who Do You Think
You Are God that's
why you got
it there was no better way for Jesus to
claim to be God In the Flesh to a first
century Jewish audience without
confusing them into thinking that he's
claiming to be the father when he's not
the father then the way Jesus speaks the
perfect Communicator the perfect speaker
who knows his audience perfectly and
knows how to get his message across
perfectly